hey this is presh to Walker
solve the following system of equations
x squared minus y z is equal to two y
squared minus x z is equal to 3 and Z
squared minus X Y is equal to five
I think Sean and Nick from New Zealand
for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
now before I get to the solution I want
to give a little bit of behind the
scenes of the process that went into
making this video
it all started in April of 2021 when
Sean suggested a problem
I made notes of it and I tried to think
of how to work it out but I couldn't
come up with a good explanation
then in November of 2021 Nick sent me
the same problem which brought it back
to my attention so I had initially found
a solution on Topper but it didn't
actually make any sense to me once I got
to this step of cross multiplication I
was just lost
I did some more research and saw
something on math stack exchange but
again I wasn't completely satisfied
so recently I posted this on YouTube in
the community section and I got some
wonderful replies from people including
Venom and JuJu Moss
so these are excellent explanations of
the problem but it still didn't
completely make sense to me in order to
make the video
so finally in February of
2023 I reworked the problem and I kept
on thinking what's the best way to
explain this so I got a video together
and that's why I'm posting it now in
April of
2023. so I just want you to know that
many times when people send me problems
it's not like I can just solve them
instantly and I can make a video and
sometimes you know people don't like the
videos they don't like the attention
getting titles they say mind your
decisions is not even part of the math
community so I want to thank you for
supporting these videos it helps me get
through it and I hope I can keep
presenting interesting problems and
explanations to you
so without further Ado now let's get to
the solution
rather than just solving for these three
specific equations we will find a
general solution where the equations are
equal to the unknown constants of a b
and c
so how do we work this out here's a
trick we're going to eliminate all of
the square terms so to do that we
multiply the first equation by Y the
second equation by Z and the third
equation by X
so here are the resulting three
equations
now what happens if we add up these
three equations
we get a magical cancellation all of the
terms on the left hand side will cancel
out
x squared y will cancel out y squared Z
will cancel out and XZ squared will
cancel out so we have 0 is equal to c
times X plus a times y plus b times Z
we can write this equation in Vector
form
where 0 is equal to the vector x y z
dot the vector c a b
so let's put this equation to the side
and now we'll do this cancellation in
one more way we'll multiply the first
equation by Z the second equation by X
and the third equation by y
here are the resulting three equations
and once again if we add up these three
equations all of the terms on the left
hand side will cancel out
so x squared Z cancels out
why Z squared cancels out and X Y
squared cancels out so we have 0 is
equal to B times X plus c times y plus a
times Z and we can write this equation
in Vector form 0 is equal to x y z dot b
c a
so now let's focus on just these two
equations
notice from the first equation we have
the vector x y z is orthogonal to the
vector c a b
from the second equation we have the
vector XYZ is orthogonal to the vector
BCA
so we want to solve for x y z
so we need a vector that's mutually
orthogonal to c a b and BCA so how can
we find such a vector well there's an
incredible tool we can use called the
cross product
so we will take the cross product of c a
b and b c a
let's calculate that out
so from this form we have the
determinant of this Matrix so we will
use cofactor expansion
so from I we will cancel out the row and
the column
so we get I times the determinant of
this two by two Matrix
then for J we cancel out the row and the
column now here we have to have negative
finally we do the same thing for K and
we have plus K times this 2 by 2
determinant
so we calculate each of these
determinants very easily and then we can
write the result in Vector form
so this will be a squared minus BC comma
B squared minus AC comma c squared minus
a b
now the vector XYZ will be some multiple
of the cross product of cab and BCA so x
y z will be T times what we've just
calculated so let's focus on this
we need to figure out the value of T so
how can we do that
well let's go back to our original three
equations
now if a equals b equals C equals zero
if you substitute that into our formula
you'll see that X Y and Z must be equal
to zero that's the only solution
so suppose instead that not all of them
are equal to zero so in this case let's
just suppose that a is not equal to zero
it'll work out similarly if B is not
equal to zero or C is not equal to zero
you just take those particular equations
but we'll just suppose that a is not
equal to zero so now we're going to
substitute this form of x y z into the
first equation so that we can solve for
t
so we know that x squared minus y z is
equal to a so we'll substitute what x is
equal to what Y is equal to and what Z
is equal to
so you substitute that in
now we're carefully going to simplify
this equation to solve for t
so we're going to first Square this term
then we have t squared in the first term
and in the second term which we can
factor out
now we just carefully need to work out
some of this algebra
some terms will cancel out and we can
simplify
from here we've suppose that a is not
equal to zero so we can divide both
sides by a
now we will solve for t squared
so t squared is equal to 1 divided by a
cubed plus b cubed plus C cubed minus 3
a b c
and then we take the square root of both
sides so T is equal to plus or minus 1
divided by the square root of a cubed
plus b cubed plus C cubed minus 3 ABC
so we pretty much solve the problem now
we figured out what x y and z are equal
to in terms of a b and c so we'll just
write it in one more way the triple x y
z is equal to the following triple
so how does this work out
in our original problem we had a was
equal to 2 B was equal to 3 and C was
equal to 5. so we simply substitute in
those values into our equation
and we get the triple of X Y and Z and
we get two possible solutions either X
is equal to negative 11 over root 70 Y
is equal to negative 1 over root 70 and
Z is equal to 19 over root 70 or the
opposite of these so X is equal to 11
over root 70 Y is equal to 1 over root
70 and Z is equal to negative 19 over
root 70. so we have two solution sets
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world problems one video at a
time
thank you